つい最近まで一緒に遊戯王やってた人が
日本一になってしまいました、はじめしゃちょーです
おめでとうございます
はい皆さん7月7日、いよいよ七夕ですね
まぁ！七夕と言えば、笹の葉に
こう、お願いごとを書いてね
短冊をつけて、祈って
まぁ叶うか叶わないかは分かんないですけど(小声)
ま、お願いごとをするっていうのが結構こうあるんですけど
この季節になるといろんなところに短冊を飾る場所があると思うんですよ
で、僕ここ最近ですね
いろんなところの短冊を片っ端から見まくって
真面目な願い事をしてる人はいいんですよ
すごい真面目で真剣に、こう家族のことを祈ったり
身体の無事を祈ったり、真面目なお願いごととかをすごい見てて
お、叶って欲しいなって思うんですけども
ごく稀にですよ！す〜ごいふざけたのがある！
もうわざとふざけてるのか、それともミスなのか分かんないんですけども
僕いろんな短冊見てきたんですけども
その中でもちょっと個人的にこれはおもしれぇなと思ったやつを
何個か見つけてきたので今回それを紹介していこうと思います
たまに、こうちょっと名前みたいなのが書いてあるのも〜あったんで
まぁ個人名は控えさせて
たまたま僕が街とかで見つけた面白い短冊を
ちょっとこっそり紹介しようと思います
ではいこう
はい、まずはこちらです「ハロウィンがたのしみ」
おい、待て待て
すごいガッツリ絵とかもちゃんと描いてあるし
10月31日だからまだずっと先ですねぇ
なんで七夕の日にハロウィン楽しみって書くのかなっていう
ちょっと純粋に面白かったです
次！
「アンパンマンのような優しい子になりますように◎※#%$@＊」
おほっw どうした
アンパンマンのような優しい子になりますようには良かったんですけど
ちょっと心が荒れてしまったのではないでしょうか
叶うといいですね。アンパンマンになれますように。
次、「みかん大好き」もう願いでもないという
みかんが大好き
次！
どうしたこれ
それもこれなんか1枚だけじゃなくて
なんか2枚〜か3枚ぐらいあったんですよ
次
「やったれやったれ」
ちょw やりますやります
次！！
「お父さんが本物のきつねになってあそびたい」
ﾄﾞｩﾙﾌwwwww
お父さんがきつねになることを何よりも願っている男の子の願いでした
お父さん是非きつねになって遊んであげてください
次！
「健康快樂」
もう快楽求めちゃってますねw
健康だけの人は結構多かったんですけど
凄いですね、もう快感を求めちゃってる
是非気持ちよくなってください
次！
「おっぱい」
はい出ました
「生きる」
生きてください、次！
「らぷんちぇるになりた◎※#%$@＊€」
かなりおしい、かなりおしいです。多分小さい子が書いたのかな？
らぷんちぇるまでは良かったんですけど、最後なりたいの途中で
心がざわめいてしまったようですね
「ファルコンパンチ」
もう技ですね、次！
「大丈夫だ  この光の始まりには君がいる。」
はい、もはや願い事ではありません
この人なんだろう、なんか皆さんにこう、語りかけたいというか
むしろ、上の方の人間の方かもしれないですね
願いのようには見えませんでした
次！
「消えない悲しみがあるなら生き続ける意味だってあるだろ。」
もうなんか、すごい有り難く感じてきました
この人願い書く気あぁる！？
もう逆になんかこれ見て、なんか勇気もらっちゃったぐらいのやつなんで
ひょっとして、もう見られることを前提に書いてある短冊かもしれません
有難いお言葉、ありがとうございます
次
「絶対に誰かと肩がぶつかる  生きるってそういうことだと思う」
ｯwww
ちょっとwww深いね
もうここまでいくと深いですよ
是非、この人の願いも届くといいですね、次！
「I want to be a game master.」
ゲームマスターになりたい男の子の短冊ですね
なんかこう、英語習いたてで書いててすごい偉いと思います
叶うといいね、ゲームマスター！次！！
「I want to be a comedian.」
ハハ（＾∇＾）
一緒に書きにいったのかな？
彼はコメディアンになりたいみたいです
是非ね、お笑い芸人目指して頑張ってください！次！
「I want to be a doctor.」
……(^ω^;)
医者になりたいみたいだね(震)
頑張ってね！次！
「I want to be a soccer player.」
いやでも英語で書いてて、いいと思います
頑張ってね！！次！！
「I want to be a back-belt Karateka. 」
おしい！！多分言いたいことは分かります
黒帯の空手選手になりたいんですよ多分この人は
なんで本当はblack-belt Karatekaって書こうと思ったんですけど
blackを間違えてbackって書いてあるんで
これだと「私は腰にベルトを巻いた空手家になりたい」になってしまいます
はい、というわけで
多分探したらもっと面白いのがあるんですけども
ちょっとパラーっと見たとき
なかなかインパクトのある短冊だなと思ったのがこちらでした
はいというわけで七夕、みなさんどんな願い事をしますでしょうか
叶えたいこととかある人、いると思います
こういう願掛けもねたまにはいいと思うので是非
七夕、短冊に願いごと書いてみてはいかがでしょうか
結構短冊見てて楽しかったんで、またなんか皆さん
面白い短冊見つけたら、ツイッターとかで送ってください
じゃあな！！ﾋｭｯ(  • ̀ω ⁃᷄)✧